survivors from the siege in palmer
arrive in the port city of pemba just
along the coast
but many others weren't as fortunate
defence officials say dozens of others
were killed
trying to escape the fighting and some
of them were ambushed
as they tried to leave palmer by road in
a convoy
the defense and security forces regret
this loss of human lives and advise that
they continue to develop at this moment
concerted actions of pursuit with the
aim of eliminating some pockets of
resistance
[Music]
since wednesday when an armed group
launched its attack on palmer
communications have been down and many
families are still waiting to hear
what's happened to their loved ones
it's very sad the situation of losing
someone it's hard
you don't know where this person is you
can't reach them or know what condition
they're in
this is horrible and it's destabilized
humanity it's
really not fair this is the only footage
that has emerged from inside the amarula
hotel where up to 200 people
have reportedly taken refuge
hundreds of others have attempted to
flee the town running into forests
and nearby villages
we don't know how we will get out of
here if we can get to the sea
or if we'll be rescued or by whom there
are helicopters flying over the hotel
they're checking to see if we can reach
the beach to get a boat out
but as you can hear we don't know if
it's possible the situation is critical
we have no food just water we're in
god's hands now
[Music]
gun battles have been going on for days
between the armed group
that caused itself al-shabab and
government forces trying to take back
control of the coastal town
there has been fighting in northern
mozambique mainly in kabul delgado
province
since 2017. this is the region major gas
discoveries have been made
in recent years but the town of palma
has been relatively safe for foreigners
working on africa's largest liquefied
natural gas project
until this week the french energy giant
hotel
has now evacuated 1 000 of its workers
and suspended
its operations it was due to restart a
20 billion
project after stopping work in january
because of security concerns
that's now on hold it was a
well-coordinated
a well-directed attack on directly on
the infrastructure
with the sole goal of trying to slow
down or stop
any kind of energy projects that are
going to happen in that region
more than 2 500 people have been killed
and half a million forced to leave their
homes
during years of fighting in the province
it's really a toxic
mix of various issues it is a
province the northernmost province of
mozambique that is marginalized
people feel frustrated they have been
people thrown off their land of
mining activities their ruby mines
specifically
amnesty international blames several
parties for war crimes
it has accused armed groups and a
government-backed private south african
military firm
of being responsible for the debts of
hundreds of civilians
it also says government troops have made
arrests without reason
tortured detainees and carried out
extrajudicial killings
security forces say fighting is still
ongoing with army officials now trying
to eliminate pockets
of resistance humanitarian workers say
it could be days
before the actual number of dead is
known and there warn
there will be even more internal
displacement as people try to escape
the fighting hara mutasa al jazeera